[Music]
today's question comes from hannah in
maryland
hannah asks how do i guide my boyfriend
in making a pivotal career move
i get to stop you right there and say
you don't but we'll continue he's 32 and
in residency most doctors go for
clinical careers but his passion lies in
medical research
the problem oh this is great the problem
is that a career in medical research
pays significantly less than a clinical
career
research grants pay about 60 grand a
year and allow you to do clinical work
making up to another
hundred thousand dollars a year
a strictly clinical career starts at
about three hundred 000 and goes up from
there if money was not a factor he would
choose the research career he has 500
000 in student loans we'd like to get
married and have a big family someday
how do i help him make sense of what he
would be giving up by going with the
lower paying option
how does one weigh their passions with
what makes financial sense is this a
case where passion needs to be thrown by
the wayside
there's so much here
there's a lot going on john
i'll let you go first
hannah
you have already spent 500 000 of your
future husband's
first year salary you've already spent
it you know what the house is going to
look like the cars
you already have the picture in your
head of how many kids you'll have and
what they'll all be doing in the big
house that you'll have
on the acres and the wherever and
wherever and wherever
this is less a question about your hus
about your boyfriend's passion
and moral question about do you love him
enough to follow him into what he wants
to do with his life
or do you love him because he's going to
make you a whole whole whole bunch of
money
now he's racked up 500 grand in student
loans right now he because y'all aren't
married he has a a problem he dug
himself a big old hole so if he was to
call in the show i would tell him
um it sounds like i would do both i
would be exhausted and do a clinical
career and do research on the side until
i could get this thing paid off and then
lean over and if he really wants to do
research you can do both in fact i think
the true res the researchers of the most
validity are those who are also seeing
patients um that's a whole other
conversation but yeah he's going to have
to figure that out financially
but that's not the question you're
asking question you're asking is can i
marry somebody who doesn't make that
much money
um yeah it feels to me that there's
there's a security thing here of well if
i marry someone who makes 300 000 i'd
feel a lot better than if they made 160.
i don't even see it as a security issue
as much as a she's living in a she's got
a fantasy yeah and you may have you may
have put your time in you may have
invested in this guy because he was
going to be a big fish
but
i mean 160k is still a great salary and
i'd rather be married to someone who
loves what they do every day and comes
home with something left in the tank
than someone who goes i hate this but
i'm glad we make good money
yeah so i'm heading off to a thing that
i hate and hope you enjoy spinning it
and again
there's much more at play here hannah
you've got to ask yourself can i be with
a guy who only makes a only makes 160.
most people are rolling their eyes going
oh my gosh it's 160 grand i know yeah
yeah knucklehead's got 500 000 student
loans he's gonna have to solve that
problem but you need to have a broader
conversation about is this the guy that
you want to be married to
can you slum it with a guy that just
makes 160
and you all need to be serious about
planning what your finances are going to
look like and when it comes to a budget
and
all those realistic things but you can
how do i guide my boyfriend making a pur
pivotal career move away from his
passion and what he wants to do
that's going to make him six figures
into
how much
well thanks for the question hannah
appreciate that